[موسيقى]
لذا يكون الجو باردًا جدًا في هذا البار ، إنها
درجة حرارة أقل من 25 درجة مئوية ، يبدو الأمر كما لو
كنت تدخل مجمدًا كبيرًا
هذا الصيف كمهرب من الطقس الحار ،
قمنا بتطوير Ice Bar هنا في
مشروع لندن وكان ذلك بمثابة  نجاحًا كبيرًا
عندما يأتون إلى مشروع لندن ،
نحن هنا على الماء في
منتصف الصيف بدرجة حرارة تزيد عن 40 درجة في
الخارج ، ثم
تدخل وتضع معطفًا من الفرو وتذهب إلى
شيء 90 ناقص 25 درجة ،
أعني أنه  بشكل غير متوقع ويحبها الناس
عند المدخل الأمامي لمكاننا ،
سترى تركيبًا كبيرًا كبير الحجم على الحائط المثلج
ودبًا قطبيًا
يرحب بك عند الباب الأمامي ، ثم
قبل دخولك إلى Ice Bar
، ترتدي معطفًا من الفرو.  معطف الفرو ثم
تذهب إلى Ice Bar نفسه ، وقد
استغرق عالم المفاجآت حوالي شهر تقريبًا لبناء
هذه المنحوتات الجليدية الكبيرة ، هناك
طيور البطريق والدببة القطبية لدينا مقعد Game
of Thrones ، هناك بار كامل
وخدمة المشروبات نحن في الواقع  ث  في أفضل
بار كوكتيل هنا في دبي ،
تحظى ملكة النحل بشعبية كبيرة هنا أنبوب شيرلوك ،
هناك إشارة أخرى إلى لندن تحظى
بشعبية كبيرة ، حتى أنك تشرب اللقطة
من كوب ثلج في
البداية ، لقد فعلنا ذلك على شكل نافذة منبثقة ، لذا فإن
فكرة Ice Bar  كان حقًا تقديم
تلك التجربة الباردة على مدار أشهر الصيف ،
لكن ثبت أنها
حققت نجاحًا كبيرًا وأعتقد أنها قد
تستمر حتى ما بعد عيد الميلاد